J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
I realize it's reading period,
so we're supposed
to be having fun.
So the structure of glucose
is really fun.
I originally had this lecture
mostly about the synthesis of
two unnatural products.
These last two lectures were
going to be about synthesis.
One about unnatural
products and one
about natural products.
But glucose is such a great
story that I couldn't miss
telling it.
So we might not get to the
synthesis of two unnatural
products, or I might just
mention it at the end.
It's also Nobel Prize
work, but so is the
structure of glucose.
And there are Nobel Prizes
and Nobel Prizes, but the
structure of glucose is a really
great Nobel Prize.
So we saw last time that there
are carbohydrates, and I found
who used the word first.
It was a guy
named Schmidt in 1844.
He said, "I may be allowed to
denote compounds [with] carbon
plus hydrogen and oxygen in the
same ratio that obtains in
water...as carbohydrates." That
is, it doesn't have to be one
to one, one carbon
to one water.
So there were examples known.
Like grape sugar was isolated
pure in 1792.
And it was given by Dumas the
name glucose, which comes from
the Greek word gleukos,
which means sweetness.
So that's where glucose
came from.
But even more important, the
-ose ending, which is just
part of the word glucose, came
to be the generic ending for
all sugars.
So when you see something -ose,
is means it's one of
these carbohydrates.
And we remember that Couper,
as soon as structure became
something that you could talk
about, because of the
tetravalence of carbon, he
proposed that there was
another water added to give the
hydrate of glucose, which
is just fine.
That would still be
a carbohydrate.
And he was right.
So you can have aldoses like
glucose where you take two
hydrogens from the top carbon,
put them on either end so you
have an aldehyde.
Or you can do the next carbon
or the next carbon and
ketones, so you can
have ketoses.
For example, fructose
is a ketose, and
glucose is an aldose.
Now, how do you know this?
Of course, nowadays we know
the structure of things by
spectroscopy.
For example, here's
the IR spectrum of
glucose, this aldehyde.
What do you notice specially
about this spectrum?
Anything?
What would you look for if you
were looking for a sugar?
You'd look for OH groups--
sure enough, big O-H peak.
And you'd look for
what other group?
Antonia?
STUDENT: The aldehyde?
PROFESSOR: The
aldehyde carbonyl.
And where would you look for
it, do you remember?
STUDENT: The C=O stretch
PROFESSOR: You look
for it around 1,700,
and it's not there.
Or you could do the NMR. So
here's the proton NMR of
crystalline glucose.
You dissolve it in D2O,
so now you don't have
the OH protons there.
And there's the proton
NMR spectrum.
And again, there's no
way downfield peak.
No aldehyde.
Or if you look at the carbon
NMR spectrum, no downfield
peak for aldehyde, or
ketone, either.
They would both come down there
in the carbon spectrum.
Of course, there wouldn't be
a hydrogen on the ketone.
So let me draw it, to try to
explain this, draw it in a
funny conformation.
Which could be in equilibrium
with a hemiketal.
Remember?
With either acid or base
catalysis in water, here
deuterated water, you could make
a hemiketal down here at
the bottom right.
So all the Os are ODs,
but here you have Hs.
Now let's blow up that part
of the NMR spectrum
that you can see there.
What peak stands out?
One far downfield.
What's it due to?
Which of the hydrogens in this
compound should come the
furthest downfield?
Leen?
STUDENT: The one that's
attached to oxygen
PROFESSOR: That's
attached to what?
STUDENT: Attach the carbons
to O.
PROFESSOR: They
all have an O.
STUDENT: Well yeah, but attached
to one without the alcohol?
PROFESSOR: The
one here, you mean.
STUDENT: Yeah, over there.
PROFESSOR: Now, that
one is on a carbon that has
two carbons attached to
it and an oxygen,
and oxygens withdraw, tend to
shift things downfield.
Can you do better than that?
There's one oxygen to withdraw
from that carbon, right?
Megan?
STUDENT: The equatorial hydrogen
PROFESSOR: The
equatorial one.
The one at the far right has two
oxygens pulling on it, the
one that's on a hemiketal.
So it's way downfield.
Now notice that there's
a little peak
here, a little doublet.
What's that due to?
Well, it could be just impurity,
but it's not.
Because if you let it sit a day,
it grows, and the other
one shrinks.
It's also downfield, so it
looks like it's got more
oxygens on it.
Anybody got an idea?
What did you call
this one, Megan?
STUDENT: Equatorial
PROFESSOR: Suppose
it had been axial.
Then if you had a ring current,
as in benzine--
you don't here--
this one would be downfield, and
the one where it was axial
would be upfield.
More over the top of the ring.
Can you get it there?
Yeah, you can go back here and
attack the carbonyl from the
other side, and get that one.
Now, how do you know
which is which?
How do you know which one was
axial and which one was
equitorial?
Well, you might use this
argument about ring currents.
People talk about that.
I'm not sure whether
it means anything.
There are other kinds of
arguments you could make that
might have to do
with that, too.
But one thing that's clear in
the spectrum is that there's a
doublet splitting here which
is about 8 Hz, and a
isn't even half as big.
So one is a big splitting, and
one is a small splitting.
Now, what is it that's splitting
this hydrogen?
Karl?
STUDENT: Sometimes that D is
replaced with an H?
PROFESSOR: So there
has to be another H on the
adjacent carbon that's splitting
that one, right?
So this H here.
And in this case, this H
here would be doing it.
But one of them is a big
splitting, and the other is a
small splitting.
Sebastian, you got an idea?
STUDENT: In the top
one there, anti.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The top one is anti, and the
other one is a gauche.
So there's much better overlap,
anti than gauche.
So this one is the
one that's anti.
That's the one with
axial hydrogen.
And this is the one that
came from the crystal.
So the crystal was
all the same.
You dissolve it and it begins to
equilibrate, and ultimately
has more of the equatorial
OD than of the axial OD.
And in fact, if you look at the
original material, just
after you dissolve it, it has
a rotation of 112 degrees,
optically active.
But after a day in D2O, it's
only 53 degrees, because the
other isomer is 19 degrees.
So people used that, before
there was spectroscopy, to try
to figure out what the ratio of
the two was at equilibrium.
Or if you really want to do
it, you do it by X-ray
diffraction, and you get
Cartesian coordinates for all
the atoms. That's what
you do nowadays.
But the interesting thing,
and what got a Nobel
Prize, was not this.
It was, how did they know?
How could they figure out what
the structure of glucose was?
Well, a lot of sugars were known
in the last half of the
19th century.
When van 't Hoff wrote the
German version of his book in
1877, he mentioned a lot of
sugars as optically active,
for example, here,
he cites glucose.
He also cites levulose.
And in fact, those both
come from sucrose.
So sucrose is a more
complex sugar.
It's a ketale that has
two of them together.
But if you take them apart, one
of them is glucose and the
other is levulose, which is
also called fructose.
Do you know why it's
called levulose?
What does levo mean?
Actually, the English word
has the same root.
Left.
Levo is left, dextro
is right in Latin.
So this rotates white
to the left.
This rotates light to the right,
and is called dextrose,
also, or dextrine down here.
He also mentioned lactose.
And it was found in 1876 that
lactose treated with acid
gives also glucose, but another
one called galactose,
which comes from the Greek
word for milk.
So it's called milk
sugar in German.
So lactose, obviously,
came from milk.
5% of milk, I think, by weight
is lactose sugar.
Or there's stuff called
mannitol,
which came from manna.
They would slash the bark of
flowering ash trees around the
Mediterranean and this stuff
would ooze out which they
called manna.
And from that, they
got mannitol.
And mannitol turns out to have
these kind of CHOH groups that
van 't Hoff was interested
in because
they made things chiral.
But notice in mannitol, the
two ends are both OHs.
The aldehyde on the end has been
reduced, in this case.
Or both ends can be oxided as
in what's called sugar acid.
So you could have both
ends be an acid.
Or you can have arabinose, which
was isolated in 1873
from gum arabic.
A gum that came from Arabia.
You know, if you're an actor,
you put your mustache on with
gum arabic.
I think you used to, anyhow.
I don't know.
And in fact, it was possible to
take mannitol and oxidize
it back to an aldehyde.
That must have been a tough
thing to do, because aldehydes
are-- very hard to
stop an aldehyde.
But somehow, in 1888, they were
able to get mannose, maybe
just a teeny, teeny bit
of mannose, doing that.
So aldehyde.
So there were lots and lots
of these known, and people
fiddled around with them, and
found out what you'd get if
you oxidized, what you'd get
if you reduced, and so on.
And on comes Heinrich Kiliani,
the hydrogen cyanide man.
Because in this paper
in 1855,
which, fortunately, I've
translated here,
he says, "While a large number
of compounds are very easily
formed upon oxidation
of dextrose"--
remember, dextrose is
glucose, it rotates
light to the right--
"by dilute nitric acid or by
halogens, these molecules
retain six carbons bound
together in a chain.
Under the same conditions,
levulose"--
The other one that came
from sucrose--
"yields substances containing
chains with a smaller number of
carbons, (like glycolic acid,
or inactive tartaric acid.)"--
That's meso-tartaric acid, OK?
"Here oxidation causes
immediate
splitting of the molecule."--
it breaks the carbon chain--," a
fact which means that levulose
is a ketone."
So that glucose, or dextrose,
has an aldehyde at the end of
the chain, you oxidize
that to an acid.
But if you have a ketone in the
middle of the chain and
you oxidize it, you
break the chain.
So it must be a ketose
of some sort.
"Bearing in mind further the
fact that levulose is
transformed into mannitol
by nascent hydrogen"--
nascent means at the time
it's being born.
They had this interesting idea
in those days that when they
dissolved sodium in alcohol,
it generated hydrogen,
but this hydrogen was more
reactive than most hydrogen,
and could reduce things
that normal hydrogen
gas couldn't do.
So they said it was nascent
hydrogen that could do things.
In fact, of course, it was the
metal actually transferring
the electrons to the compound
to be reduced.
But anyhow, he said,
if you do that with
levulose, you get mannitol.
Which, remember, was the
thing that has OH on
both ends of the chain.
So if it was a ketose, a ketone
in the middle chain, it
already had alcohols
on the end.
But if you reduce the ketone
to an alcohol, then you got
alcohols all the way, much
like mannitol, which
they got from that.
So one comes to the conclusion
that levulose must be adjudged
to have one of the following two
constitutional formulae.
Either CO--
they can't be the
first carbon.
That's the aldehyde.
That's the one where you reduce
it or oxidize it, it
doesn't break the chain.
You just get an acid there.
If it's a ketone here,
you break the chain.
What if it's a ketone on
the next carbon down?
Why didn't he consider that?
Matt?
STUDENT: It's the same as that
one.
PROFESSOR:It's the
same as the one above, right?
There are only two.
OK.
So is it I, or is it II?
So he goes on in the paper to
say, "One could hope to
distinguish definitively between
one and the other
formula by succeeding in,
adding HCN to the ketone
radical of that levulose and
transforming the cyanhydrine
into the corresponding
carboxylic acid."
So you add CN, hydrolyze
it so it's COOH.
It adds to the carbonyl
carbon.
So from compound one,
you would get this.
Add in CN here and turn it
into carboxylic acid.
From compound II, the ketone
on the next position down,
you'd add here and get
that carboxylic acid.
So the question is, if it has
this structure, then you add
HCN and HCl.
You get this--
and it's very concentrated HCl
he used, incidentally--
or if it's the next one
down, you get this.
OK.
So you do it and decide.
All you have to know is
which product you get.
Get it pure, see what it is.
The problem is, these things,
as almost all things are in
sugar chemistry, are syrups.
It's very, very, very
difficult to get
crystals from them.
So it was really hard, in those
days, to purify things.
Nowadays you to do
chromatography, maybe, or
something like that.
But then it was essentially
impossible.
So they had to try to make
things simpler so that they
had a chance of crystallization.
He says, "It must, upon
exhaustive reduction by
concentrated HI, yield methyl
butyl acetic acid."--
so this one--
the one on the top--
would give methyl butyl acetic
acid, reduced with HI and
phosphorus.--"
and on the contrary, the
carboxylic acid from compound II
would give ethyl
propyl acetic acid.
So all you have to do is know
which of these you've got.
And he said, this is fine.
But when he did the reaction
and got the product, which
should be either this or this,
he says, "[It] does not agree
with the description that Hecht
gives of the Ca
salt of methylbutyl
acetic acid."
So Hecht, he said, had done
a lot of good work on this
compound, including making
the calcium salt.
He was able to crystallize
the calcium salt of
the product he got.
And it didn't agree
with Hecht.
So he says, "which means that my
heptanoic acid is identical
with ethylpropylacetic acid."
So this is the one he's got.
But that compound wasn't
known, so he couldn't
be sure about it.
But anyhow, he concluded that
it must be this, since it's
not Hecht's compound.
Now the next year, in 1886, he
reacted ethyl acetoacetate.
So this is acetyl group
on acetic ester.
What's special about
those hydrogens?
Active methylene adjacent
to two carbonyls.
You make the anion, you
can put an R group on.
You can make the anion again,
put another R group on.
So he put on ethyl.
Put on propyl.
And then, what I told you last
time is that when you
hydrolyze this, you get
the acid, and then it
decarboxylates.
So from the acetoacetic ester
synthesis, you lose CO2 and
get a ketone.
But he did it differently
in those days.
He used really, really
strong KOH, which
doesn't give a ketone.
It gives acetate.
That is, the hydroxide
attacks here.
Acetic acid comes off,
generating that anion, which
then picks up a proton
from the acetic acid.
So you have acetate
and an acid anion.
Which you then put a proton
on, and you've got this.
So he made authentic stuff, but
it didn't agree with what
he got from levulose.
So now from Hecht, he knows it
wasn't this, and from his own
work, he knows it's not that.
So now he began to wonder
about Hecht and just
how good Hecht was.
So he went on and did the same
thing, putting on methyl and
butyl, to make this.
And he compared it with the
product from this, and found
that the calcium, barium,
strontium, and lead salts all
agreed in their properties.
So Hecht was wrong.
He said at the end of the paper
that Hecht is going to
go back and look at this
a little more.
But at any rate, he was then
able to prove that levulose or
fructose has that structure.
The carbonyl is in the
second position.
So he now knows the constitution
of fructose.
This paper from 1887 is on the
composition and constitution
of arabaric acid
and arabinose.
So now he's going to look
at a different sugar.
And what he says is, "In a
report dated 27 November 1886,
I showed, on the one hand, that
arabaric acid, formed by
oxidation of arabinose, has the
formula shown there, but
on the other hand, described
several derivatives of
arabinose carboxylic acid
with the formula C7."
So it was uncertain whether
arabinose was a five carbon
sugar or a six carbon sugar.
If it was a five carbon sugar
and he oxidized it, he'd get
five carbons.
If it was a six carbon sugar,
and he added HCN to add
another carbon, he
would get C7.
So here says, he admits
that he had said
contradictory things.
One that implied that it
was C5, another that
implied it was C6.
"Since at that time I had no
basis in truth to dispute the
generally accepted formula for
arabinose, which is that it's
C6."
The analyses are very similar
to one another, whether it's
one or the other.
"and my analytical results
did not contradict either
assumption."
So he couldn't be sure whether
arabinose, the stuff that came
from gum arabic, was C5 or C6.
So he took arabinose.
He added HCN He made the
arabinose carboxylic acid, the
stuff that he talked
about up there,
but he said then it was C7.
Here he made it with one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Here he made the six--
assuming that it starts
with five, right?
And he was able to reduce that
with sodium with mercury to
get mannitol, which was
known to be C6.
So it was clear that arabinose
wasn't a C6 sugar.
It was a C5 sugar.
So he had resolved this.
But it was pointed out that--
One of the reasons it was
difficult to work with this
was this original
compound was a mixture.
Why would it be a mixture?
Because the cyanide could add to
either face of this carbon
to make right- or left-handed
carbon.
And these other carbons are,
of course, chiral, too.
So you get diastereomers,
depending on which
side you add from.
This was pointed out by someone
who was very sensitive
to not just the constitution,
the sequence of bonds, but to
the configuration of these
sugars, which is going to make
a lot of difference.
With so many chiral centers,
there are going
to be lots of isomers.
So the person who pointed that
out was an Emil Fischer, who
was three years older than
Kiliani, and died much sooner,
for reasons you'll see.
So one thing he did with
Kiliani's acid--
this is the acid you get by
adding CN to the five-carbon
sugar, and then hydrolyzing
it.
So Kiliani treated it
with sodium and
mercury, and got mannitol.
But Fischer did something
different.
Bear in mind, this
is a reduction.
So you take the acid all
the way to the alcohol.
It's very difficult to
stop at the aldehyde.
But Fischer found a way to stop
at the aldehyde, which
was to first heat it to make
this lactone, a cyclic ester,
and then reduce that with sodium
and mercury, and now he
got the aldehyde here.
Now, why was that handy?
Because it gave a way
to convert one sugar
into another sugar.
Now you could make new sugars
synthetically, because it was
possible to stop at
the aldehyde.
So a Kiliani-Fischer
synthesis on
arabinose gave this compound.
So Kiliani-Fischer synthesis
elongates an aldose, makes it
one carbon longer.
OK.
Now, that wasn't the reason
Fischer got the Nobel Prize.
A contributing factor
was phenylhydrazine.
When he was a graduate student,
he synthesized
phenylhydrazine, and he loved
to make derivatives with it.
Remember, we talked about how
you could make derivatives of
carbonyl compounds with N-N
things to make imine bonds,
and they're very strong,
if you have two Ns
together like that.
So he could do it with sugars.
You could react with a sugar,
and make an imine.
It's called a hydrazone,
right?
Now, this hydrogen here is
allylic, so it could shift up
to here and make the
double bond here.
But now this hydrogen is
allylic, and it could shift to
there, so you can get this.
Now you've got another ketone.
So what's going to happen?
You can make another
hydrazone.
So now you've used the second
mole of phenylhydrazine.
So now that one's allylic.
You can shift it over here.
Here we do a cyclic
rearrangement.
This hydrogen goes
to that nitrogen.
This bond breaks.
These electrons go here to make
a double bond, becomes a
single, double.
So it breaks apart into
two molecules,
one of which leaves.
And now we have a C=N double
bond, which is very like a C=O
double bond, so you can get a
third molecule of
phenylhydrazine
to react and make a
new C=N double bond, losing
ammonia, and you get this
compound, that has two of his
favorite molecules stitched
in there.
It's called an osazone.
It's a hydrazone that's made
from an ose, from a sugar.
By treating this with his
favorite compound,
you could make this.
Now, it was his favorite
compound, but
it's also deadly poisonous.
And he poisoned himself very
badly for almost a decade
he was in very bad health
because of poisoning
himself with this.
And in fact, in 1919, he
committed suicide.
He had cancer at the time, and
who knows whether it had to do
with exposure to his
favorite molecule.
But if what was so dangerous,
and he knew he was being
poisoned, why did he
like it so much?
It was because ozasones
are crystalline.
Remember, these sugars are
always syrups, and you can't
do anything with them.
But with crystals, you could
purify and tell what things
were, tell if one thing
is the same as
something else or different.
So that was the beauty, for
him, of phenylhydrazine.
That you could make an
osazone and identify
things in sugar chemistry.
So he was interested in
identifying the structures of
these things.
So let's try to be systematic
about seeing what the
configurations could be
of different sugars.
Let's look at the hexoses.
We all we already
have erythrose,
arabinose, and xylose.
Arabinose came from gum arabic,
xylose came from wood.
Erythrose comes from a lichen.
Eryth means red in Greek, so
erythrose was because it came
from this red plant.
But there were also hexoses
glucose, mannose, galactose,
and gulose.
And all these were identified
by Kiliani as being aldoses.
Aldehydes, not ketones.
We showed how he could tell
the difference there.
So these must differ in
their configuration.
Right?
Now, how many should there be?
If you have six carbons in
a chain that ends in an
aldehyde, how many
should there be?
Well, for this purpose,
we could write them
all out like this.
This is a particular one,
using what projection?
STUDENT: Fischer projection.
PROFESSOR: The Fischer
projection.
And one of the most amazing
things about Fischer is that
he figured this all out without
having the Fischer
projection.
It's easy for us to trace his
thought now using the Fischer
projection, but he used van 't
Hoff's notation, which was
very, very complicated.
And I have never
figured it out.
So that's one of the real
triumphs of Fischer, was to be
able to think through this
stuff without Fischer
projections, which he published
the next year.
But we could abbreviate that
Fischer projection by writing
it that way.
Whoops, I wrote it wrong here.
These lines show which
way the OH points.
So the bottom, you don't
care, it's not chiral.
The next one, the OH to right,
OH to the right, that one
should be OH to the left,
OH to the right.
So the code is clear.
Now we can just write out
all the possibilities.
So there are four chiral
carbons, so there are going to
be 16 possible isomers.
But if we're looking only at
the D-sugars, those are the
ones that are all to the
right on the bottom.
We could draw the mirror image,
too, the L-sugars.
But let's keep it simple just
by showing the D sugars,
because as Fischer well knew,
he had no way of telling D
from L. You could measure the
rotation, but not the absolute
configuration.
So let's just assume that
a given compound
is D in the D series.
Now, how can you draw
them all out?
You can draw right, right,
right, right, left, left,
left, left.
Then you can go right, right,
left, left, right, right,
left, left and finally right,
left, right, left, right,
left, right, left.
So you've got eight isomers,
and four of them must be
glucose, mannose, galactose,
and gulose.
But not arabinose and xylose,
because as we just saw,
Kiliani showed that arabinose
was a five-carbon sugar, not a
six-carbon sugar.
It's a pentose.
An erythrose is a tetrose,
a four-carbon sugar.
And finally, at the top, you
have glyceraldehyde, the one
that Fischer chose as the
reference for what's D.
So the question only
is which is which?
And at first glance, that looks
impossible, until you
come along with X-ray or NMR,
maybe, or something
to figure it out.
But Fischer figured it out.
So here was the evidence
he used.
You can look online on the
website and see the
translation of his paper,
how he actually did it.
Almost all textbooks nod and
cover this a little bit,
because it's realized what a
great contribution it was.
I mean, it's like Shakespeare
or something like that.
But they all mess it up.
They use modern reagents, they
say it should have worked this
way, or something.
This is what Fischer actually
did, so you can read about it.
But anyhow, this is the
evidence he used.
He found that glucose could be
oxidized by nitric acid to
make the compound that
is an acid on
both ends of the chain.
So it's symmetrical with
respect to acid.
Not just the aldehyde, but also
the primary alcohol got
oxidized to an acid.
And then he did his heating to
make a lactone reduce it with
sodium, which made it back
into a sugar again.
And the sugar he got
he called gulose.
It's different from what
he started with.
You'd think if you oxidize and
then reduce back again, you
got the same thing
you started with.
But he could get a different
sugar this way, Why?
How could it be different?
It could be the aldehyde was
on the top, made two acids,
reduced the top to an alcohol
and the bottom to an aldehyde.
So now it's upside down, so
you'd have to rotate it.
So it could be a different one
of these sugars that we drew
on the last slide.
And he decided to
call it gulose.
Why?
It's a sort of an anagram.
It reverses the U and the
L. Glucose, gulose.
Because he went end for end.
So, you know, chemists sometimes
have sort of geeky
senses of humor, right?
So gulose.
So that was the first
evidence.
And then subsidiary evidence for
that is that the diacid he
got on the way is
chiral, and both
enantiomers of it were known.
That's the first line
of evidence.
The second line of evidence is
that glucose and mannose give
the same osazone.
Remember, he made osazones to
make crystals, but glucose and
mannose gave the same one.
Also, arabinose, if you do a
Kiliani reaction, gives two
different acids.
Gluconic and mannonic acid.
We talked about that before,
that it could add either side.
And fructose, when it's reduced
to give alcohols all
along the chain, gives two
different alcohols, glucitol
and mannitol.
And notice all of these are
glucose-related and
mannose-related.
So there's some special
relationship between glucose
in mannose, that all three
of these things do that.
The second line of evidence
is mannitol and
mannonic acid are chiral.
So if you have OHs on both it
ends or acids on both ends,
it's chiral.
Bear in mind that people were
just fiddling around, seeing
what they could make
from what.
But Fischer collected the key
items of evidence that could
be used to make a real
logical argument.
So third, arabinose, when
he did a Kiliani-Fischer
synthesis, gave glucose.
But also, it gave mannose.
Right?
Now we see this relationship
between gluc- and man-.
And xylose, which
came from wood--
that's the, like, xylophone,
right?--
xylose, wood sugar, by the
Kiliani-Fischer synthesis,
added a carbon and
made gulose.
Remember, this one up here.
And also another compound
which I think is one
called idose now.
But these aren't really
relevant.
But then 3a, arabinose.
If you make two OHs, or two
carboxylic acids on each end,
is optically active.
But xylose gives inactive
compounds with OH on both
ends, or acid on both ends.
In fact, that was tough.
Because arabitol has
no rotation.
You put it in, you think
it's not chiral.
But if you add boric acid,
then it rotates light.
Remember, it's hard to know
what causes rotation.
And it just happens that
arabitol has no rotation, or
unmeasurably small rotation.
But if you make a derivative
of it, then you can see--
and the acid is rotating.
So it required a lot of work to
know these things for sure.
So that's the evidence, and
therefore, he knows what
glucose is and what all
the others are.
That's pretty much of an
accomplishment, right?
Just to conceive that on the
basis of this evidence you
could figure it out
is amazing.
And this is only fifteen years
after van 't Hoff proposed the
tetrahedral carbon, and
a lot of people still
didn't believe in it.
So here are the hexoses
and pentoses.
And we're going to go through
his lines of evidence and see
how his logic worked.
Evidence 1 was that glucose
gives a diacid, and on heating
and reducing, it gives gulose.
So when you turn it end for
end, then you've got a
different compound.
So let's go across and see.
Would that be true of this?
If you turned it end
for end, would it
be a different compound?
Remember, with a Fischer
projection, the idea is things
turn out at you.
So can't rotate 90
degrees, but you
can rotate 180 degrees.
So if we rotate this one 180
degrees, do we get the same
thing again?
That is, what you do here with
this is make a dot on the
bottom and not on the top, so
then you have to rotate it to
bring it back into this series
that we've drawn here.
Right?
Obviously, those would all
point to the left.
It would be the mirror image
of the one we started with.
So we'll put that on the back
burner for a second.
How about the next one?
If you turn that end for end,
does it look the same, if you
put the dot on the bottom
and rotate it?
Obviously different.
Is everybody with me on
its being different?
That one will be different.
This one, however,
will be the same.
If you rotate it 180 degrees,
it's going to be left, left,
right, right again.
If you change top to
bottom and rotate.
So that one is not glucose, nor
is it gulose, because if
you rotate end for end
it's different.
How about the next one?
Will that be different?
Should we take it out?
That'll be different.
Will that be different?
Ah, that's going
to be the same.
Not different.
So we can take that one out.
How about the next one?
Will that be different?
That's going to be like the
first one, where everything
that's right is going to be
left, everything that's left
is going to be right.
So we'll put that in abeyance
for a while.
And the last one also
is different.
So from Item 1, we know for
sure that it's not that and
not that glucose.
Now, item 1a--
and we're not so confident about
that, because it changes
the hand in this only.
But the diacid is chiral.
Both the enantiomers are
known when the two
ends are the same.
So with this one, if the
two ends were the
same, would it be chiral?
No.
It would have a horizontal
plane of
symmetry through the middle.
So it can't be that one.
This one, would that have
a plane of symmetry?
No, No.
That one's out already.
How about that one?
No.
Ah.
That one's out.
That wouldn't be chiral.
The last one would be chiral.
OK.
So from 1a, we confirm
that it's not that
and it's not that.
So we're down to four
candidates for
what could be glucose.
Now we go to Item 2.
Glucose and mannose give
the same osazone.
Remember what the osazone did?
It made a double bond at the top
carbon and a double bond
at the next carbon.
So that means this next carbon
here isn't chiral anymore.
Right?
And if you take arabinose,
start with that being the
carbonyl and add CN, it can
add to either side.
One would give that, one
would give that.
Depending on what arabinose is,
one would give this, this,
one would give that, that, one
would give that, that.
So again, it says they differ
only at this second carbon.
And fructose, which has a ketone
at the second carbon,
as Kiliani showed, gives
two alcohols.
So it could give this alcohol
and that alcohol, this
alcohol, that alcohol,
and so on.
So anyhow, what that means
is you disregard that.
So this Item 2 shows that
glucose and mannose differ only
in this carbon.
So now, when we look at Evidence
2, we know that if
this is glucose,
this is mannose.
They differ only at that carbon,
which this shows is not
relevant here.
OK.
So if this is glucose,
this is mannose.
If this is glucose,
what's mannose?
This one, right?
If this is glucose,
this is mannose.
And if this is glucose,
That's what
Evidence 2 shows.
Now, Evidence 2a is
that mannitol,
OH on both ends, or acid
on both ends,
those molecules are chiral.
So can this be mannose if the
two ends are the same?
Is it handed?
No.
So this can't be glucose.
How about this?
Could this be mannose?
If the two ends are the same,
will it be chiral?
No.
It doesn't have a mirror
in the middle.
It's a propeller.
It's not a chiral.
The one that's right at the top
and left at the bottom is
the mirror image of this.
Not identical to it.
So it could be could
still be that.
Could this be mannose?
Yes.
That means this could
be glucose.
Could this be mannose?
No, because now it has a
mirror in the middle.
So that can't be glucose.
So from 2a, then, we can exclude
this, and we can
exclude that.
So one of these must be glucose,
and the other one is
gulose, the one that's turned
end for end, top to bottom.
So how we going to decide
that, or how did Fischer
decide that?
He went to Evidence 3.
Which is, arabinose, in the
Kiliani-Fischer synthesis,
gives glucose, and xylose
gives gulose.
So one of them gives one of
these, and the other one gives
the other one of those.
So we know something now about
arabinose and xylose.
They can't be this, and they
can't be this, because that,
on a Kiliani-Fischer synthesis,
couldn't give
either of these, and this
couldn't give either of those.
So those are out.
That one's out and that one's
out for arabinose and xylose.
But what we know from Evidence
3 is that if this is glucose,
that one had to be arabinose,
the thing that you add another
carbon here and make that.
And if this was glucose, that
would be arabinose.
And vice versa.
If it's arabinose,
it's glucose.
So if we know arabinose, which
is arabinose and which is
xylose, then we know which is
glucose and which is gulose,
because of those connections.
So Evidence 3a is arabinose
gives optically active
arabitol and arabaric acid.
When the two ends are the
same, it's chiral.
But xylose is not chiral when
the two ends are the same.
OK.
Could this one be arabinose?
Would it be chiral if the
two ends are the same?
How about that one?
No.
So that one's got to be
arabinose, and that one's got
to be xylose.
So we know that glucose
can't be this, because
it comes from arabinose.
So that one is glucose.
So he proved it!
So all these known compounds
were then assigned.
If you knew this was glucose,
then you know that was gulose.
You know that glucose
and mannose differ
only at this carbon.
So you know which mannose is,
you know which arabinose is,
which xylose is.
You also can figure out which
one it erythrose is, by making
arabinose from it.
So all these things now work.
It's like the end of a
solitaire game, when
everything begins
to work, right?
So you now you get all
the other sugars.
In fact, of these sixteen
sugars, the right- and left-
handed ones in the bottom row,
the hexose, of the sixteen
Fischer made, thirteen
of them himself.
And he made fifty artificial
sugars overall
in the 1880s and 1890s.
So he got others.
Like he also got threose.
So this was a new compound.
How did he name it?
Where did the name threose
come from?
It's erythrose turned
around, right?
Sort of turned around.
Or he got ribose.
Like ribonucleic acid,
deoxyribonucleic acid.
Where does the name
ribose come from?
STUDENT: Arabinose.
PROFESSOR: From arabinose.
From gum arabic.
Or he got lyxose.
That's pretty obvious.
Or you got talose from
galactose.
T A L, OK?
Or he got altrose.
He was beginning to run out,
so this just means "another
one." Alter, right?
Or he got idose.
That's idem, you know, the same
as the one above in a
list is idem.
So it's another one, right?
Or alose, which is the Greek
version of altrose.
So he got all these, and
he got the Nobel Prize.
And he got the second
Nobel Prize.
The first Nobel Prize
went to van 't Hoff.
Not for chirality, but for his
work in physical chemistry.
But the second Nobel Prize went
to chirality via Fischer,
because everybody realized what
a great contribution--
you know, it's not
just doing it.
but doing it without Fischer
projections is a lot tougher.
It's to conceive that you can
do it, that the evidence is
there, that you apply this new
theory that van 't Hoff came
up with not so long ago, and
follow it through with
rigorous logic, and
you've got it.
Rather just fiddling around,
making this, making this,
he puts it all together.
He finds the crucial bits of
evidence and puts them
together to do this really
beautiful proof.
So I thought you would want
to know about that.
Now, if you want to remember
it, the guy
who taught me Organic--
I took Organic Chemistry
the way you are, 50
years ago this year.
And the guy that I took
it from, Louis
Fieser, made up this.
"All altruists gladly make gum
in gallon tanks." And I
remembered that for
fifty years.
So I have no trouble doing
alose, altrose, glucose,
mannose, gulose, idose,
galactose, and tolose.
It's not a very fundamental
contribution to science, but
it's very handy, if you want
to teach about hexoses.
And if you want to do
this one, it's raxl.
R A X L. And erythrose and
threose, you just remember.
OK.
So hooray for Emil Fischer.
Now we've got two minutes
just to show you--
I'm not going to show you
how this happened.
It's going to be a stream
of consciousness thing.
You're not responsible
for it on the exam.
But I've got all the slides
here, so what the hell, right?
And it is a neat thing.
OK.
So we talked about
cyclobutadiene.
Is it antiaromatic?
Make it and see what
its properties are.
The problem is,
So you can make it by this.
Shine light on it.
It closes up in in a disrotatory
process.
And then with light, it loses
CO2, and you get it.
So study its properties.
The problem is that it undergoes
a really quick
reaction with itself.
A Diels-Alder reaction,
which gives this.
And then that opens up, because
it's very strained, of
course, and gives
cyclooctatetraene.
So you get cyclooctatetraene,
which is sort of evidence that
you had cyclobutadiene, but
it's not like knowing its
properties.
So the problem is that it
reacts with itself.
So it's presumptive evidence
of existence.
Could you do spectroscopy?
So you have to make it, somehow,
under conditions that
it won't react with itself.
So if you made it inside a cage,
like a big clam shell,
so only one molecule was in
there, then it couldn't react
with itself.
So they made this compound
with a guest inside.
So it's two big, like
a clam shell.
It holds the precursor inside.
There's a mouth that you can
put things in and out from.
And it was done by Donald Cram,
who got the Nobel Prize,
and Martin Tanner, the son of
Dennis Tanner, who burned his
eyebrows off with a Fourth
of July demonstration?
They grew back again,
you know, he was
not permanently marred.
Thomas, I don't know.
So these R groups were big
things to make it soluble. And
it was that, and you can make
that by thinking backwards
with an aldol reaction.
So first, they make the bottom
half of the thing, and how to
form this big ring with
sixteen carbons in it.
You take resorcinol and
hydrocinnamaldehyde, and then--
This is very active for
electrophilic substituition.
So you protonate that, you have
an electrophile, it forms
a bond, ortho-para, you've
got the first bond made.
Put that in, dehydrate, you can
react it was another one,
so you've got another one.
Now you just keep doing
it to make all
those all the way around.
But you could imagine lots
and lots of different
ways of doing it.
And it turns out that the
electrophilic aromatic
substitution is reversible, and
ultimately, this compound,
the one they wanted to make
this, precipitates from the
equilibrated mixture
in a 69% yield.
That is luck.
So the fish jumped into this
particular boat, right?
But now they need these bonds
across the top of
that bottom, too.
The teeth for the clam.
So what they did is they
put bromine on.
Then they made anions here with
base, and reacted with CH2
with two leaving groups.
So one leaving group, the
other leaving group.
And now do it on all the others,
and you've got those
carbons put in.
Now you have to join the top
half to the bottom half.
Oh, they got this,
incidentally.
They didn't get a 69% yield.
That was 5% from the tetramer.
And they had to isolate
it by chromatography.
So now they had to join the two
hemispheres, which they
put a lithium on in place
of the bromine.
And then they put boron on, and
then hydrogen peroxide,
which we've seen before, to
make those into alcohols.
We've seen that before.
So you see, this was really to
be review of stuff we've done.
So now you've got alcohols
all the way up.
So you've got the Os that are
going to do the bridging.
And now you just do that same
thing you did before, to put a
carbon in, this carbon the same
way you did that one by
having a carbon with
two halogens,
so two leaving groups.
And now again, when those two
things come together, if you
have three things that can react
here and three things
that can react here that
can go like that,
which is what you want.
It could go like that, it could
go like that, it could
go like that.
There are lots of
different ways.
But it turned out that
they got 40% of it.
40% of this stuff
went into that.
Overall, from the stuff they
started, and it's a 1% yield.
But they started with
a lot of stuff.
So they had the clam shell.
And now it turned out they
could get the guest out.
This is a crystal structure,
so this stuff at the top is
chloroform, and this
is solvent.
There are two different
solvents in there.
But in the middle of
the cage is DMF.
This is that clam shell here.
And these things are just put on
to make it soluble, so you
can work with it.
OK.
So they could get that stuff
out, and they could
replace it with this.
So here's that stuff on the
cover of Angewandte Chemie
inside that compound.
And this is the NMR spectrum.
So most of the peaks come from
these hydrogens in the shell.
But the ones marked in red, and
one that's under here, are
these four hydrogens on
the starting material.
And then they photolyzed it, and
they got the purple peaks.
It changed.
And then they photolyzed
it again, and they
got just one peak.
That's the peak of
cyclobutadiene.
And it can't react with any
others, because there are no
others around.
And then if you get it out
again, then it will react to
give cyclooctatetraene.
So this is way upfield,
antiaromatic.
As we talked about before.
Now, is that what causes
the upfield shift?
Because you'll notice
something else.
If you put benzene inside, its
normal position would be here.
But benzene inside that
clam shell is there.
It shifted way upfield.
Why?
Because it's above all sorts
of other benzene rings.
Remember, when you have
something above but a benzene
ring, it's shifted upfield.
If it's out beside it, it's
shifted downfield.
But this, the one that's in
the middle is above all.
So some of that shift must be
due to the same effect that
makes benzene go up.
So most of the shift comes
from the other rings.
Still, it's about one and
a half ppb above
benzene, so it is shifted
upfield and it is
antiaromatic.
So I think that's what
I wanted to show you.
That's the end.
But the big lesson is how
Fischer did glucose.
Thanks.